You're marketing yourself
in a way,
you're providing value,
which is what
real marketing is, you know.
It's gotten harder and harder
to do that on Twitter.
A big thing that
frustrates me sometimes
is like the dynamics
with airdrops now.
I farm airdrops
all the time too,
but what's changed is
like the idea behind
incentives isn't a bad thing,
but the way that
we've executed on them
clearly is not working.
We have to figure out
a better way
to like retain users.
Part of that is just
by building better products, for sure.
But the other thing is
like the models also clearly
not working anymore either.
Oh, like these airdrops,
like oh, you keep blaming
farmers and stuff.
And it's just like no,
this is what
evolution looks like.